foreign we can also report tonight that
Herschel Walker an incumbent Senator
Raphael Warnock are headed to a December
runoff in Georgia as neither candidate
hit the 50 percent threshold to win
outright now this is a race that will
likely determine Senate control and ask
yourself how many Georgia voters still
don't know all the details about
warnock's extreme record past scandals
like you know calling cops comparing
them to Thugs and gangsters being
accused of after a domestic dispute with
his ex-wife of trying to use a car to
Runner over ran over her foot this is
now time to expose all of it Herschel
Walker joins us uh Herschel I would
imagine that you probably would have
liked to have gotten a 51 uh 50 plus one
but I also got to imagine you'd never
thought you'd get into politics here you
are in a runoff and one of the most
significant races uh this election
season that will have a profound impact
on this country
well it is son and I never thought that
I ever do this but I think the Lord
prepared me for a moment like this right
here because
right now I know that a vote for
Herschel Walker is a vote that the
Georgia people voices could be heard in
Washington DC not only the people in
Georgia but America voices give could be
heard because a vote for a senator
Warner is going to have Kamala Harris
making the decision for them and I'm not
going to let that happen I'm going to
fight and I think people have seen me
fight and uh they're trying to bite his
seat they're going to do everything they
can to buy their seat so I'm gonna need
your help everyone out there helped to
say guys we're not going to let them buy
this seat I want everyone to go to
teamhercial.com because you see now that
I'm gonna fight they're going to have to
come through me to get to you and I'm
not going to let that happen
you know I look at this background and I
wonder if if people that just want a a
regular steady Democratic you know vote
a steady vote and they look at Warnock
as basically a rubber stamp because when
you look at his record you know here you
have a guy that wants to end cash bail
uh legislative filibuster cops are are
compared to Thugs and gangsters you know
you look at the rest of his record do
you want CRT in in schools being taught
uh he's got a terrible track record he
ran a camp and there were allegations of
child abuse he was arrested for
obstruction of justice you know praising
Farrakhan Jeremiah Wright Fidel Castro
are people in Georgia aware of all this
because I think if they were I lived in
Georgia four years that's not the
Georgia that I know that would vote for
people that think like that
well you said something earlier the
media is not my friend the media going
to put my record out there but yet I've
been transparent with everything I've
ever done and he hasn't but let's not
just talk about that record let's talk
about him as a senator as a senator he
get an F he has not spoken for the
Georgia people I think the people have
seen who he who he represent he
represents Joe Biden and the people
there in Washington because he's voted
with him 96 percent of the time and we
don't need to keep saying that then I
think the people can feel it they can
see it and right now we're in a tie
breaker and that's why I said I'm not
giving his seat up because right now the
Georgia people are hurting because
there's inflation the Georgia people are
hurting because of crime on the street
kids right now got men and women's
sports all the different things that
happened in less than two years since
he's been in office and I'm not going to
let them continue to destroy Georgia or
destroy this country so I'm going to
keep fighting right now we got less than
a month and uh and I can put up with a
month because right now this seat means
is a lot bigger than Herschel Walker and
I know they're going to throw more at me
even the kitchen sink but I can catch it
I'm gonna catch it and keep moving
forward
you know I will tell you I I would argue
that's probably true I mean it's it'll
be as ugly as it can be but you know
what uh they could say whatever they
want about you because there's an awful
lot on him and his positions and his
statements over the years uh I hope the
people of Georgia get educated on all of
this because if they do I believe you
win hands down Herschel Walker
congratulations look forward to December
the 6th and we'll be following this very
closely thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else